yes indeed I'm here with Anish giri who
just finished his game in a draw what a
game it was Anish I mean it's I mean I
wonder what you were thinking during
many times and how many times you
calculated Knight F2 and all this on
each move probably yeah well I knew this
stuff I don't play like this when I'm
prepared I'm not this kind of
guy I don't go night G4 F5 Knight F2 if
I'm not prepared so uh I knew that um
this there's Knight G4 D5 uh and F5 and
frankly here uh the line I recollected
is Bishop
B2 uh and there is this very forcing
line black has options but this is like
the why I'm am I showing okay too late I
already showed it but uh there is this
uh forced um Knight D4 and now you can
take Rook E2 but I think Knight C5 is
also there uh and I think there this end
game I was analyzing this end game
little bit if white can be a bit better
here after Knight F2 Bishop A5 C6 but I
think surprisingly it's it's quite
drowish even though it looks like a bit
better for it but but also there was um
Rook yeah Bishop D4 C Rook e
to and when I was analyzing it I was
checking which one is the easier draw I
think IUD that this is probably the
cleaner one but uh anyway Bishop B2 is
the the force line black can also play
more ambitiously than that it was sort
of forc payout but I'm sorry it was
forced and was clear for you was it
wasn't so clear probably for ala who was
spending quite a lot of time what well I
don't know afterwards he told me when I
send him to line he said that maybe he
had seen it before but he somehow didn't
quite uh recollect details of course
Knight G4 D5 is the is a weird way to
play uh black can play many different
ways like usually they go like Bishop A7
I mean I had games with white like that
as well it's kind of slow play H6 but
sometimes you go for D5 sometimes not
but in this particular case white hasn't
gone H3 so I have this I've prepared
this Force line yeah I mean it was sort
of an attempt to uh to try and just
completely Force um Force the draw I'm
I'm curious actually Pizer was
mentioning that he will not be surprised
if you know everything until you know
yeah no I'm surprised this engine here
gives some number I think mine was
giving a smaller number I guess this is
not very deep one cuz I think this
position if I remember correctly it was
completely nothing but um it looks of
course a bit better I think yeah I was
kind of thinking maybe this is a little
something but I think I kept analyzing
it and it was okay but yeah H3 is um is
the other w i i didn't recollect because
I thought H3 was not the most principled
way and I was frankly kind of mostly
calculating uh logical yes what happens
if you take yeah I didn't see here yeah
the point is that I I want to take first
here so that if BC then I go Knight F2
mhm Rook F2 by the way I was thinking
Queen D6 first more precise than taking
because yeah d8 so this I liked and if
uh N9 C4 now I'm not taking on F2
anymore I'm going now E4 that's why I
take on C4 first yeah but there was some
interesting lines you know if uh you
take immediately and then there is some
crazy move like B5 yeah maybe next time
yeah next time pet maybe you've seen it
no Bishop C4 first I'm pretty sure KN C4
E4 um but what was fascinating in the
game yeah actually knight1 yeah he
should have played I think this is the
the correct zero D4 here was very
interesting because I had uh I saw
Knight F2 is forced equality so it was
hard to uh I mean it was a little hard
to refuse it because it was very easy uh
Force line but of course I felt that he
might have already pushed it too far so
I was trying to find Advantage here okay
the reason I didn't do this is because
in the worst case you can even go a g
mhm EF and something like this and
Bishop E3 whatever I don't buy this big
Advantage for for black um but of course
this was not the main reason I didn't
play the main reason is I missed the
amazing line here after Bishop yeah Rook
D1 is uh Bishop Queen D5 Rook D1 that is
uh good for white I think Queen D3 is I
think at least equal for white but the
principal line is EF and here I missed
an amazing he also missed it and that's
the pity because okay I don't know if he
would have seen it at some point uh
but we were going to he was going to
lose it here actually he was going to go
Bishop H4 this is the reason why I
didn't play it as well but this this
absolutely unbelievable line this only
move Rook F2 yes take and I mean I I saw
Rook F2 with the engine after the game
there and then as I was walking towards
here I realized the point and why I
didn't see it of course it's amazing you
go Rook E8 here h g and then you go
Bishop G3 and you my go Bishop G3 is
unbelievable move and I mean there were
there were there was a chance he would
have fallen for this e won there is no
def a good chance though of course he's
he had I mean ag ag is there but AG is
not why I refuse it I think I can even
go Bishop
F2 oh no this is not nice yeah Ean is
not nice sorry so maybe I should go Rook
F2 yeah I don't know I mean uh yeah okay
is the threat right there so yeah he go
here for example he goes here because
it's really un I take he goes Bishop
[Music]
H4 yeah I mean such things the thing is
that my knight is a bit dumb on C6 so
maybe white has some attacking potential
anyway I I will frankly the thing is
that it was just um it was just not
smart to do this I felt because I
thought that I allow this bishop G5
after which I didn't see frankly okay I
mean I missed this actually this was my
issue I just didn't make this work
because what I calculated here is uh nor
is a there's nothing to to even
calculate right yeah this is just bad so
I thought of course about Knight F2
yeah but I think there was just no even
queen2 there's just no this good
Discovery so um what else did I see yeah
there's not much else I just didn't see
the I mean I I missed Rook F2 all
together but I I guess even if I had
seen Rook F2 it just doesn't make much
sense here because you see Ean take take
a g and rookie H E1 te taking H2 me you
have to see this rookie 8 H is amazing
uh incredible res like like Queen C1 no
here already I'm the queen yeah it's
just amazing it's in uh but yeah I I
suspect that white is still okay here um
with something precise but it would have
been curious because um at least the
line we both saw is the is losing for
him so it's not like I missed a win and
it was a classical game so he had a lot
of time but maybe he would have fallen
for it but okay he's of course a great
tactician maybe he could have find
something later it's always I was not
even yeah yeah but I was not even I was
not really close to find this I mean
this is just such a next level cheap
that I mean I don't think I'm um capable
of this kind of things really I mean in
a practical game where I don't know that
there is a solution like of course if
you tell me here F Bishop G5 you say
okay black to play and whatever win yeah
yeah then I can find it for sure because
by elimination but when you don't know
the final outcome absolutely then you'll
see the normal options you not looking
for something insane when you don't know
it's there so I just yeah and also
frankly I maybe I misjudged but I just
thought that this like I even GF like I
thought like what's going on here maybe
it's also about respect to your opponent
that he will find all the best moves he
will do the mistake no respect no
respect this no don't don't you know put
words in my mouth zero respect to
opponent it's just that I'm calculating
also okay I mean I have time I can play
Knight F2 any time and make the EF que
D1 easy easy draw though frankly from
afar I missed EF um like I thought this
is also actually thought I'm better then
I realized after e there's no good
discoveries and after Queen D1 I
realized here I don't have any Queen H1
business but checked it a little bit
there's nothing right no yeah so I have
this Knight F2 in the in the back so I
spent like I know that you shouldn't be
like you know it's waste not to think
about Fe when you have time so I was
thinking about Fe I was like diligently
thinking about it but I um I knew that
I'm not missing much because there is AG
but simply there's Bishop G5 I just
didn't see that amazing resource and
it's very very one of the more beautiful
things I had seen that could have
occurred in my own game so okay my last
question can you agree on this statement
that you are the best prepared player in
this tournaments there is a very good uh
no no I'm not I mean here especially uh
the tournament is spe with people who
would definitely debate that uh I'm
trying um I'm really trying to be the
best prepared player but I think the
same is about Fabiano and Yan I think
they both also have Ambitions to to be
the best prepared player in the world I
I think um
Maxim Leon and
Wesley uh are less ambitious about it
right now I mean Leon used to be at some
point the best prepared in the world but
the problem is that even if you
are like better prepared overall in a
particular game you can still get
totally um um shocked by I mean and I
once played a game against opponent who
is not known to be an opening player
when he uncored some incredible know
against me so in particular game it
won't matter and I really don't think
that in this tournament you can say that
I'm the best but I'm of course trying
and there's a funny video of Hikaru uh
you know hikaro yeah heard interesting C
hiar and um so hiar at some point
there's a video where he talks uh he
talks about me and uh there's actually
nice edit of that there's like a niche
counter so the number of times hiar says
my name and think it's like 15 in the
end okay he says my name 15 times in the
video so it's yeah it's a nice video and
he there says that he thinks I'm the
best prepared player in the world I said
okay Fabiano most maybe at some point um
but yeah I honestly don't think so
especially nowadays if I don't work for
3 weeks I think in a row on chess then
I'm already behind Fabiano and um Yan
and yeah ala is also very interesting um
because he I have a feeling he works
sort of in you know in the spurts U
sometimes he is full of ideas and then
he starts to he also has a different
approach sometimes he plays more um more
of the slow things where he relies on um
practical skills rather than prep so he
has a different approach uh and also of
course we we shouldn't forget the
Carlson who is not playing here but he
is also still trying to be really well
prepared absolutely and okay the Fight
Continues about everything about the who
is the winner of single cup who is
better prepared all the best of luck for
you Anish and uh see you tomorrow I hope
I hope I
hope well have to do now it is a hope
isn't it